foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to another episode of bonehead
of the week
how are you doing this week Gabe good
just I just enjoyed that little you know
the little ditty you know
it's out of our Norm because you don't
really yeah yeah this one is just like
uh what a bunch of babies little
children right it's like a kid's show
Almost yeah you know it's fun it's
entertaining bonehead of the week
because we're like given an award for
someone to be a [ __ ] bonehead so
right exactly yeah speaking of boneheads
let's see our contestants here this is
who we had uh on the bonehead of the
week I kind of [ __ ] up the the uh the
poll though I know I know well you know
what happens but we did have like almost
a thousand votes imagine if we had more
days on the pole yeah well so what
happened folks what happened was is my
dumb ass maybe I'm the bonehead of the
week yeah
we'll mention yeah well I I could go I
every week I could probably be on the
dishonorable mention somewhere uh but
but no I I posted the poll and I was so
excited about getting these three people
out there the three people you see
Christian Walker Lauren bobert Mark
Meadows I was so excited about getting
them out to the pole to the to the
Twitter page the podcast Twitter page
that I I didn't set the poll to uh to do
to go all week I think I accidentally
did it for like two days instead of like
four or five so you didn't get to vote
all week the good news is let's look at
the Bowl here the good news is is you
get like a thousand a 935 votes that's a
lot yeah and I think it's because these
people are such [ __ ] boneheads of
course this one I think this is this the
tightest race that we've had between all
three yeah yeah but yeah everyone else
has either been a blowout or uh two of
them have been like relatively close but
this is the first one where it's like
stacked you know right because I I think
Christian Walker was ahead for a little
while yeah yeah yeah and the reason why
is because some of the videos we're
gonna show about him wearing like a
twelve thousand dollar hoodie bitching
about a ninety thousand or nine ninety
dollar tank of gas in his Land Rover a
ranger or whatever he's a big uh and we
can talk about it too I mean like we
have history and I'll even mention some
stuff oh you and him huh yeah yeah we go
back okay we go back yeah well
way back huh yeah so so so back or so
much that uh people at UCLA will send me
stuff on him that were in his classes oh
okay so he went to UCLA he still goes to
UCLA oh that's is that where he lives
yeah he well he lives out here in LA and
minding for people who are listening or
watching like UCLA is a very expensive
School in the area of LA because I'm
also in La the area of La where it is is
like
big homes like that it's it's not for
the normal person to live like it's got
money over there what what you're saying
is someone who can afford a 1200 hoodie
can live in these neighborhoods yeah in
a Land Rover and you know all the other
things uh so he's wearing so he's
wearing a hoodie in Los Angeles is that
a thing yes he's wearing a hoodie
because that's just I got my hoodie on
today I got my hoodie on today but I'm
in Missouri it's [ __ ] starting to get
cold here so I put my hoodie on yeah no
La it's that's just part of the style
you know yeah but it does get it does
get chilly I mean like you know it's
like in the 50s so which is not like
super chilly because like the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ] yeah
it's [ __ ] freezing outside yeah well
anyway that's you know it gets a little
nipply sometimes people people in
Colorado on YouTube are like shut your
[ __ ] man like there's like 12. all
the people that hate Lauren gobert who
are listening are like yeah [ __ ] it's
cold but also [ __ ] you because that's
not cool well speaking of Lauren bober
we got her back on a list this week you
know what's funny is we've been debating
like we talked about this list a couple
times and we we've been trying to figure
out why we put it on the [ __ ] list we
finally figured it out
um and we'll probably go over that today
but but she is she's such a [ __ ]
reoccurring bonehead that even even me
and you who pick kind of pick who's on
the list couldn't figure out why the
[ __ ] she's on the list yeah I think it
was a comment it was definitely a
combination of like there was so much
[ __ ] that hit the fan this week for
boneheads and also you're talking about
the text messages mainly yeah yeah
mainly the text message and like the
response to them right but also uh on on
her side it's that she had you know she
was on she was dishonorable mentioned
then she was on the list and then you
know she
uh was putting herself out there to to
be the bonehead and she did it you know
she doubling down herself out there
exactly I mean so yeah but that's why
it's like she's trying to win our poll
really honestly I think she's just
looking for his poll over on the Tony
Michaels podcast
it's called bone in the week and I want
to win every [ __ ] week they do this
video where if you win and like she's
striving to yeah she just wants to I
mean if she wants a video of herself
every week I'll do it just make it I'll
just make a special bonehead you know
she's you know what's last week we uh
it's funny because last week we used she
was our dishonorable mention last week
right if you remember and we actually
reused that slide like we didn't have to
remake it that's how [ __ ] that's how
[ __ ] boneheaded this idiot is yeah
she tripled down she was like I'm I'm
going all for it and then she won the
next week didn't she yeah she won the
next week yeah I think so so like
honestly we should just email her that
video so she could yeah yeah we could
you know just yeah we should just keep
her Keep Her On retainer as a grown head
of the week you know right right and
then we have we we have the the the
winner this week is Mark Meadows he got
you know almost 45 so not not even a
majority
um a a you know over 50 percent this guy
yeah
um he had even even being held in
criminal contempt for orchestrating the
Cheeto dust kangaroo coup
um this guy this guy that's how bad
Christian Walker and Lauren are I guess
I don't know I I don't know what that
says yeah I don't I mean like Mark
Meadows and we'll probably find out more
as the the you know weeks go on right
before the holidays but uh
you know he is this he is at one of the
people in the center of this web of uh
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know right
um it's just like you know the [ __ ]
text man well you can come back the cree
the crazy part is is that
so many people knew that the way the way
to get the president to stop the
Insurrection was to text Mark's Meadows
right like everyone's debating rather oh
you know they're you know they're
bullshitting rather he's gonna pay a
price are these people gonna go to
prison and all this [ __ ] and like really
to me just the fact that that it's very
clear
that everyone knew what was happening
and they knew who to get a hold of
because they knew he was standing right
next to Trump yeah but also the other
thing that you know has been brought up
too which I think is a valid point is
the fact that none of the text messages
that went to Mark Meadows ever said
anything about like checking in on the
situation of trump right like is he okay
what's going on right right it wasn't
like are you guys in the bunker yeah
yeah it was like tell him to make an
announcement like did it just it just
jumped well because they knew they knew
exactly they knew and he knew it
everyone knows this it's just the
jarring part is to get the the you know
the evidence so let's let's get to it
let's let's talk about um our
unfortunately the the loser of the week
you can see I checked marked here
Christian Walker because I wanted to
give him a head start as soon as I did
the poll and the reason why is because
of uh these videos that we've got of him
uh let's see let's play the video that
everyone was kind of kind of you know
pissed off about here and let's see
here it is
now Keith's got it uh published here but
this was done by Christian Walker videos
I mean you were talking about this
beforehand we're not sure at this
Christian longer videos is like a it's
like a parody trying to make fun of this
guy or just trying to get his [ __ ]
on Twitter because he's banned from
Twitter right no no no no he's banned
from Tick Tock and that's actually part
of the uh wait wait wait Christian
Walker is on Twitter
uh-huh yeah oh I did it's it's Christian
Walker and The e is a one
so Christian walk Warner was was he was
he uh was he banned or is that just
because there's other Christian Walkers
and he wasn't able to capture that
uh I don't know but that's just the one
that he has across different social
media I just know this was posted on
Instagram and was pulled down and posted
on a Twitter he didn't post a Twitter
that I know of but he was a fan on
Instagram yeah he's definitely on
Instagram and he's he's verified on
Instagram too what's funny about that is
right Winger's like oh Facebook and
Instagram are so left-wing I'm like give
me a [ __ ] you got this drive on there
come on once he got verified he was
bragging about he's like oh yeah now I
can like dm with all these other
verified accounts and also the [ __ ]
but he um it makes me want to get
verified yeah well no I'm serious just
just to say I see see me
validate me right please but he also got
he he got banned from Tick Tock twice he
got banned once uh for his videos uh and
then he came back and did videos this is
car videos that he does because he does
him in the car he says his stupid he
does yeah he says all his dumb [ __ ] in a
car where he's yelling and uh it's
either in his in his bedroom or in his
house
or in the car and it's typically when he
is
um in line for Starbucks where he was
like in the drive-through and he'll be
ranting like there's a video wait wait
so he's trying to he's trying to appeal
the normal average J country folk and
there's this here's this this kid in a
in a Range Rover in the Starbucks
drive-through exactly 1200 hoodie on oh
yep yep so he's going through and he
complains about that and so anyway he
goes on his whole thing uh I actually
you know what I'm gonna let me share a
video because it's the it it's the
contrast that he has so let me just
share this okay yeah yeah go ahead all
right well while you're doing that I'm
gonna play this video so we hear this
yeah y'all said Joe Biden was going to
be the great y'all the fire this is
divisive to my bank account and my hard
earned money so the first thing is I
didn't know this because I'm not like a
designer at the designer clothes
um expert or whatever I didn't know what
this brand was on this hoodie like I
just I would think that this was just a
really shitty hoodie with some kind of
weird word on it right I don't know but
apparently this is like a 12 000 already
1200 whatever 1200 yeah right yeah
whatever you're gonna call it a twelve
thousand dollars you can spend 1200 on a
hoodie you'll spend 12 000. okay uh most
people would be like yeah you're gonna
do that so but but the other thing too
is when he points watch him when he and
let me back it up
he's pointing he doesn't know which one
is the he doesn't know which one is the
gallons and which one is here's the
thing he doesn't I just want to point
this out for anyone listening or
watching Christian Walker does not have
a job he does not earn money he gets
money from his dad Herschel Walker he
has on several occasions bragged about
the fact that he's like I'm rich and I
got this and I am this because I am uh
lucky to have my parents who were blank
blank blank and he I think he even
doubled down on those things which I'm
like yeah he did some kind of whiny
video after yeah he was like and and
it's one of those things where I'm like
you think you're making a point
but you're not making it sound as good
as you think because you're like oh yeah
like you understand people and their
problems and you're complaining about
gas when in reality that's not your
money nor do you have to worry about it
and the fact that you're now bragging
about how rich your parents are and how
much you have only distances yourself
even further from the average person
right you are trying to uh map this but
he courts him but he courts them it's
like this Candace Owens thing right
right where you know back to the
Herschel Walker thing before I go on
here I had no idea that this is Herschel
Walker's son I really didn't know that
yeah I have no idea yes there are no
idea I don't think you're alone because
there are definitely people when I've
done my videos where they're like wait
wait wait that's his son and I'm like
yeah I didn't yeah I I didn't like I
seen this guy on Tic Tac because people
would Stitch him and [ __ ] right because
you know he's a [ __ ] idiot just like
and and again he does the whole Candace
Owens thing where he's like
uh Democrats hate black people and and
they're actually the ones who are racist
and the Democrats started the KKK and
you know Democrats killed Abraham
Lincoln all this stupid [ __ ] all this
dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] that they don't like
they try to go back and you know rewrite
history as if you know we didn't have
this major party shift in this country
uh when Harry S Truman who was running
for president of the United States looks
and says hey
um uh you can be racist just not in our
party you know they forget that part of
history but he's doing this whole
Candace Owens thing let me let me fast
forward it because I don't want to watch
this whole thing really
to afford to get to work that's unified
afford to get to work says again you
didn't have a job fine that's bringing
the nation together screw this so the
gas prices are divisive which meaning
meaning this [ __ ] [ __ ] thinks that
the president controls the price at the
pump which only only gives me more
evidence that he's never bought gas in
his entire [ __ ] life he pays someone
to take his Range Rover to the gas
station and fill it up don't you think I
also yes and I also think that or like
you know even if I mean like clearly
someone's recording so it's like who is
recording right friend or an employee I
don't know you know
so that the person who normally fills
the gas tank is recording is that what
you're saying I think possibly yeah
because he's like oh look at this I
think even once he said it's like in the
video he either says under my guy you
were paying 30 bucks or a third or
something like that and I was like tell
me when the last time a Land Rover cost
thirty dollars to fill up gas because
that's not just like that's not 87 it
might be 89 or 91 because that's a
that's a nicer I can see if we can see
that okay here's the screen let's do the
[ __ ] math here so he's get he's got
60 because of course he wouldn't be able
to do the math and he's probably never
concerned himself with like oh how much
is gas so 62
divided by 13 right now
so it was 4 470 something like that 474
which is not uncommon I mean also keep
in mind that where he gets gas he lives
in a very rich neighborhood right so
you're right but here's the point now
here's the point I want to make here
because he made this video a couple
weeks ago right yeah
and it just popped up on Twitter now
here here's the thing Donald Trump just
said with with the Huckabee interview
that gas in California is seven dollars
a gallon I can verify that is not true
and if it is true it is that like it's
very isolated remote that's the only
place you would ever see gas where it's
like super Christian Walker is
confirming it here right here on this
video Yeah well clearly if the math you
know easy division here and you'll find
out that you're nowhere close to seven
dollars per gallon but I can tell you
um you know I've got like a you know a
like a
a mids it's like not an SUV but it's a
it's a truck you know uh between like a
hatchback kind of thing and do you do
you have like an El Camino is that one
no no no no I mean like no I don't I
wouldn't be that's actually that could
be a cool car I don't know you know like
a flat I like El Camino yeah might as
well uh but no I don't have one of those
but what I'm saying is like you know I
and there are obviously different gas
prices in my neighborhood and different
gas prices in Los Angeles right but
nowhere in Los Angeles are you finding
seven dollars worth and even that whole
thing was called out
well yeah so apparently
um there was one gas station that
recorded seven dollars a gallon like
right where was that located though
right well but it's been a long time ago
that it was recorded and they're just
pulling that one thing out yeah that's
like that's like when they said that the
shelves were all empty and people like
this is footage from 2020 when Trump was
President not one Biden is right right
look at look at these pictures of the
Shelf empty or or who was it uh I forget
who maybe it was Bridget Gabriel or
maybe with someone else I forget
um they posted a photo of empty shelves
and people like oh what's that weird
squiggly line
on the prices and that person had posted
a photo from uh the UK and it's like you
couldn't even get the [ __ ] country
right oh dumb [ __ ] yeah yeah what a
turd but you see him pointing here in
the I'm not gonna play the rest of this
video we're gonna go to your video here
in a second but do you see that you see
him pointing at the gallons there the
gallons don't really matter I mean it
kind of does like I mean the gallons are
absolute so that's never going to change
well but it will change if you buy like
a really big SUV and expect it you know
to not spend a lot of money to fill it
up because it's got a big gas tank and
shitty gas mileage like I don't know
like a Range Rover or something maybe
right the people yeah and it really
comes back to the people that complain
about trucks it's like for whatever
reason you bought it for work purposes
or you bought it to be you know right
you know show off right uh
I don't want to sound insensitive but
you bought something with a large tank
and every time you fill it up you're
gonna have it whether it's one time or
it's uh the frequency is spread out over
several times you're still gonna have to
pay more money than someone who is just
driving a sedan well when you go to the
dealership and you're worried about you
know how big you can make your dick look
as opposed to the gas mileage you end up
you end up with these kind of problems
okay so let's Cody let's go to your
video here and uh let's see can we bring
that
get out of it
anyway so this is this is her uh again
for everyone listening or watching this
is Christian Walker this is a typical uh
Day in the Life
um oh oh you know what actually there's
a side note I want to make here he has a
brand new car
that is not his normal car that is a
brand new Land Rover in in this video
that we're showing you yeah for yes uh I
don't know how recently he got it but I
can tell you for a fact because I've I
are you stalking Christian Walker it
sounds like I only know that because of
the videos that I do where I quote
unquote sit in the back seat where I
splice the videos yeah okay he doesn't
have that sunroof in any of the other
videos so this is a brand new car
just pointed out there so for someone
who's complaining about gas prices the
kid bought from his dad a brand new car
let's just let's just put that on the
open there so that everyone knows uh the
fake outrage but this video here that
I'm playing or that you played is an
example of Christian Walker at the
Starbucks drive-through and his typical
routine is he'll go through he'll rant
about some [ __ ] and he'll be like
blah blah blah blah blah and then
the or like he'll he'll literally be at
the order like booth and they'll uh
they'll say like oh what can I get you
and he's like hi and like the shift as
you saw right here this like it's like
stark contrast always makes me laugh
because he goes from completely insane
to just like so soft
and it's just I can't not laugh
like just those videos by itself I'm
just like you're a [ __ ] idiot
speaking of videos and you stalking him
oh yeah you sit in his back seat a lot
that's what they say see this is a
different this is a different that's a
different car see it's a different
sunroof just saying well let's let's
let's let's verify this because because
you're you're all up in the [ __ ]
Christian Walker thread here you know
that right I tell you when Christian
Walker and Gabe Sanchez is it seems like
you're stalking him game
so we go we go back he and I and he and
I go back where he found my videos and
um this is one of them right yeah yeah
he was reporting my videos on Tick Tock
and getting wait wait so he was he was
like reporting him as like bullies
bullying and harassment and so then I
had to then go and say oh I you know I
uh I want to appeal did you get your
video back
uh some of them I did and some of them I
didn't I mean one time I called him a
cuck and that video got removed
yeah I called him a [ __ ] in the video
because he was like not
he there's a video where I'm on I'm
FaceTiming him and he's like I just
can't I can't come to terms with the
fact that Biden's present in that kind
of thing and I said something like
listen it's just the one where he's in
his kitchen because I think I've seen
that one
[Music]
let's play this video and let's show the
folks at home what this I'm a triple
Major honor student at the University of
California Los Angeles setting Chinese
International Development in French
that's ironic yesterday UCLA publicly
tweeted that the dean of students had
been notified of a certain student's
hateful Behavior online and that they
don't approve of it I wonder who that's
about dear UCLA just because I don't
fall into your communistic totalitarian
leftist politics doesn't mean I'm
hateful I'm truthful I'm in America
Freedom loving Patron's my country my
Constitution and my president Donald J
Trump run to your safe space and get
over it Christian picking a fight with
UCLA is a delicate idea also you can't
even speak French I'm a triple Major
there's a backstory to this internet
okay go ahead so the back sort of this
is I told you that my videos were like
blowing up on Tick Tock right and and he
was getting upset and he was he was
reporting these videos right so so I was
like oh I can't you know tag him or
whatever it needs anymore but I ended up
getting people from UCLA who were dming
me on different platforms and revealed
they were basically spilling the tea on
Christian Walker so the whole uh French
thing this is the back sort of that that
was the first or second day of class or
whatever you know they're all on Zoom
the teacher says you know this is a you
know uh a higher up class where it's
like we're only going to speak in French
and the teacher's like all right go
around introduce yourself and say
something interesting
so this is like French not French 101.
no no this is not French 101. this is
like Advanced French yeah yeah
right yeah at least hold a conversation
and be like my name is blank and I do
blank right unfortunately how it really
played out was they go around and the
teacher comes to him and then he's like
a blank face Blank Stare doesn't say
anything and the teacher's like you are
you there like uh you know what is the
like is there a bad connection or
something and then he was like
well I I'm just
I
yeah I haven't really I've spoken French
in a while so like I don't really know
you know and so the person that I was
speaking to about this they're like it's
not a very like if you've been in French
like there's very common phrases and it
doesn't take a lot of you know like
knowledge to know it and he just stood
there Frozen
and it was further proof that like he's
majoring in something that he knows
little about or has talked about
something he knows a little about or you
know knowledge there was there was a
bunch of people that went to federal
prison in uh California I believe it was
trying to get their kids into Elite
schools when they didn't yeah there's a
documentary about it too you know yeah
yeah I want I wonder yeah I'm just I'm
just snowballing here but yeah it's
quite possible right well you know maybe
maybe he wasn't I mean he was on the
French team I know right yeah he brags
about uh because he's like oh UCLA is
seventy thousand dollars or something
like that I'm not sure the exact tuition
but it sounds like the average person
can afford that exactly yeah yeah right
but he brags about it non-stop
especially when UCLA comes in he's like
oh I got to do this thing and I had to
like say that I was vaccinated and I was
like yeah because you have to go back to
class he is fascinated yeah I'm
guaranteed he's vaccine oh 100 but he
gets really he's like if you don't want
to get vaccinated then don't get
vaccinated if you want to get vaccinated
get vaccinated like he's very like right
well so here's the thing like he rails
on UCLA but then he brags about going to
the school right so it's either a
leftist indoctrination Cesspool that is
you know a uh a factory for the
Democratic Democratic blood second cabal
or it's not like it can't it's not both
you can't let's see what his roommate
says in this one we are 24 hours out
from January
we're all hoping Trump unveils some
crazy evidence or Trump trump does
something crazy he won't do [ __ ] the
vice president has the authority to
reject Electoral College votes tomorrow
if he so chooses you might want to read
the Electoral count Act of 1887. so if
hence doesn't step up and do his
constitutional let's hope it's not in
French if he has to read it I'm just
yeah well you're gonna catch me being a
dragon I'm sorry could you just say
dragon oh come on Christian let's not
kid ourselves here you're more like a
garden snake
yeah boom baby
speaking of the day before
January 6th I have something that I want
to play here and I'm not going to play
the whole video yeah I did a video and
someone brought it up
I want to play this here this is number
two let's talk this is one of my uh
walking rounds let's get to the part
where edited uh yeah I think this is it
right here
I'll give you a little [ __ ] dose of
reality here if the vice president
really did have the power to pick who
the president was why in the [ __ ]
hell would Joe Biden pick Donald Trump
in 2017 you dumb [ __ ] it's
deluded little [ __ ] Lupo exist us
radical socialist commies would have
took power and took over the country you
dumb [ __ ] idiots perk up a better
[ __ ] plan would you please [ __ ] them
my number two is better than your number
two so that was that was I posted that I
think I did that on January 5th but it's
funny that uh I played the Christian
Walker video there that uh um you know
he's talking about how this big huge
plan uh how they're gonna get to any
[ __ ] bonehead what a [ __ ] bonehead
speaking of boneheads let's move on to
uh Lauren bobert I really don't want to
take much time with her because I feel
like she's going to be the winner here
in the next couple weeks like Yeah well
considering the fact that you know I'm
sure uh texts or phone records will come
up uh sooner than later and will reveal
that uh yeah she was you know like I
even made a video a while back which was
uh
uh based on some early Whispers okay
look here look here that yeah but I made
a video of her giving a tour in the
capital oh yeah yeah that's right the
early Whispers of that going on and
she's since uh stated she's like I never
give a tour I never did that you know
and I was like of course she did if
she's saying she didn't right so so this
is this is this is organic folks I I
just typed in Lauren bobert and the
thread here oh [ __ ] your favorite a t
guy been at the very top uh what's ATT
customer service I think I think did you
like intentionally try to work your way
into the uh bonehead of the week here a
lot no here's the thing like I have
there's a lot I have a lot of ideas in
my head and whether they end up like I
end up writing a script for it or not
you know it depends but this is like I
wanted to do this video two days prior
like I've got so many videos that I want
to film but I you know for work and
other purposes I don't have all the time
in the world so this one was intended to
go out on like Tuesday day or or
Wednesday when these two were actually
trending because the subpoena went out
but then I finally got around to and I
posted this yesterday now this this is
this is because she was bonehead of the
week I think originally because she
posted a tweet about you know a
gazillion children going on missing or
some [ __ ] she was totally off on the
number right yeah just and again Twitter
ate her up because she misspelled
something which was not the not what
they should have been appalled about is
the absolute [ __ ] line she was
spreading but anyways I think we talked
about that last week on the podcast but
we she also her and Marjorie Taylor
green their phone records were
subpoenaed because apparently they were
texting someone or some ones plural
um and I guess we'll find that out let's
let's play this rendition of what their
reaction was Marge hurry up I'm deleting
them as fast as I can hi this is Ben
with ATT customer service how can I help
you we need to delete our text messages
we hey Marge here well short story long
our phone records were subpoenaed by the
January 6 committee I just want to warn
everybody before we get to a certain
part because this this week Gabe's had
this obsession with like half naked
um the picture that you're gonna see
here on the screen I'm going to give you
a trigger warning
because it's got a familiar face and and
the the back story is he actually
floated this picture to me before he
made this video and uh I had to actually
Wipe Out the entire the entire thread
just to get rid of it because it kept
popping up but I just want to give a
trigger warning here is it Marge that
shows her or her screen yeah it's
because they it's it well right for the
America first thing right yeah yeah it's
for their little like whatever romance
that was let's continue to play if your
phone records were subpoenaed then ATT
probably already handed them over Lauren
do we have to delete every message yes
even the news
Okay Phone Doctor
um how did we like delete this my name
is Ben and you can't delete that we
store your data here at ATT fine but
like what if I get a new phone you know
like new phone who did it we still have
that but like what if I go line by line
and white out every text on my phone oh
my God ma'am you cannot use whiteout to
delete your texts okay but like like
what if I try to drown my iPhone in the
toilet oh better yet ask them what
happens if we throw our phones in a wood
chipper like in Fargo you do know this
call is recorded right
hurry up I'm deleting so only that would
happen you know the break-in what is
that footage from is that from so that's
so there's a there's a meme I've used it
before for another video yeah it's just
it's just a funny ending but uh the it's
based on a a YouTuber yeah
um went and had a party and then it was
talking about like spicing things up and
what ended up happening was he had all
this [ __ ] go down and then he had these
like fake FBI people break in to the
house
through the ceiling all it's a it's a
crazy uh the original video is pretty
crazy but it's like one of those YouTube
prank people kind of thing
um but yeah it's got a good ending and
actually this is so this is where the
white out idea came from and I told
I
I told Jesus that I was like I was like
God damn it now I have to make this
video and I have to include it in uh in
the in in this like yeah you see Jesus
Christ Our Jesus [ __ ] Christ here
yeah posted a picture
of someone deleting a text right just
waiting out whatever the message was but
once I saw it I was like oh man I gotta
I Gotta Throw a line at least in for
this that's good thank you Jesus [ __ ]
Christ yeah for making our day on that
one
all right well let's see if Gabe works
his way into the the uh the Winner's
Circle Mark Meadows here because uh Mark
Meadows was our uh our winner this week
and you've been in every category so far
you've been in every cat your videos
have been every category and I have
another Mark Meadows video but I wasn't
able to finish it so I'm hoping i'll
release it maybe tomorrow you're making
the Tweety tweets and the trendy Trend
rounds here
um so but let's let's give Mark menos's
do and let's let's play the winner video
here yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
congratulations Mark you won way to go
Marky Mark Everyone likes the winner
video yeah it's the yay at the end it
goes back to the kids show yay yay right
and the the kids show theme
um uh Claire bear here is at the top
when I don't know how all of a sudden
this Mark Meadows story has turned into
a lot of other characters
um and when you search Mark menos this
is the top of the feed here and it says
when Jim forwarded a text to Meadows he
broke the law so that's what uh Glenn
kirschner too but he went on and we're
gonna watch the video here I think he
went on uh joyanne reads show readout
and he said that that um apparently the
text messages is a 20-year felony now I
think people need to be careful about
saying this kind of [ __ ] because you're
getting people's hopes up here but uh
but if it is a crime
um we definitely need to smoke that out
and know that [ __ ] so I'm gonna give
Clear Credit here well the other thing
too is the the people
um
who
are involved with this situation like
they're you know they send texts or know
someone who sent a text or whatever it
is uh
they you know and if they've been called
out instead of just ignoring it and
being like let's see how this plays out
they are jumping in and defending
themselves right and specifically as a
lot of Fox News people obviously there's
Jim Jordan and anyone else but uh the
people are
um
just bringing more attention to
themselves and there's a ton of posts
with you know Hannity and large Trump
and Jim Jordan and and uh and Laura
Ingraham and speaking of Laura Trump
we'll get to that yeah yeah we'll get to
that but uh but all this stuff they use
their platform to to bog down to like
just suppress or attempt to suppress the
fact that they are Innocent but in doing
so it either
crimes right it sounds a little bit more
than just like I wasn't involved
so here is a video of Glenn talking
about this controversy between Mark
Meadows the vice president and possibly
Jim Jordan but I want to show
um the video because it is some here
somewhere here in the feed I think
because we had Rick Perry in the [ __ ]
mix I mean all these characters come out
that was a recent Edition that one came
out yesterday right maybe he'll be on
bonehead of the week next week yeah um
but here is uh this is the readout let
me give let me give joy credit
Joy follows me on Twitter thank you Joy
for following me on Twitter by the way
yeah she follows me hashtag blessed she
doesn't follow me yeah no I I appreciate
her follow him and she's uh she's
retweeted a couple of my videos so I
appreciate Joy retweeting my videos but
and so I'm gonna retweet her stuff here
but but um this is where she's asking uh
several people Glenn in particular about
um this Rick Perry thing so we're gonna
hear about it in the video here
um because it's about two minutes and 20
seconds so let's let's listen to this
clip and let me come to you on Miss
Glenn because the question then is did
these people come in a crime you know
you we've now seen that members of
Congress were texting guidance to the
chief of staff saying hey here's some
ideas on how we might be able to undo
the election CN CNN is now reporting
that one of the other people who was
sending you know strategies to try to
help is Rick Perry who used to be the
governor of Texas and then join the
administration that he so that so the
strategy thing that's what kills me is
like he's like and this is like November
4th he's texting this yeah this is the
election right what man like they knew
he was gonna [ __ ] lose yeah well
three weeks after when it when Biden was
announced the President right but I also
think for them is like whether they knew
he was going to lose or not was the fact
that they had a contingency plan set up
in place to be like if he loses then we
will go forward or at least we will
float this idea right of overturning the
election and then of course you know you
enough enough people and then now we
have the evidence so let's let's
continue at least according to CNN he
denies it was pushing this aggressive
strategy
supposedly
um to try to also overturn the election
and get Mike Pence to do it
um again Perry denies it but you know
CNN says he was one of the people that
was doing it
um you had multiple house members saying
here by the way of course letting this
really bananas PowerPoint that says that
China and indeb Hugo Chavez and lots of
other people were still in the election
these things are I love the Hugo Chavez
Theory it's great that is incredible you
can't make that [ __ ] up the congressman
that Jim Jordan is a traitor to the
Constitution I also believe there's
probable cause that Jim Jordan committed
a crime by forwarding that text to Mark
Meadows and here's why Jim Jordan
forwarded a text so I want everyone to
know that Glenn is going to say Glenn is
a former Federal prosecutor
um which doesn't mean that he gets to
say who gets prosecuted
um because a lot of people are out there
saying a lot of stuff but he's going to
make a case here of wiring why what Jim
Jordan did is actually criminal
um so we'll listen to him and then we'll
go to his video and we'll talk about it
urging Meadows to tell vice president
Pence to throw out electoral votes to
basically undermine Joe Biden's win and
he did it after Donald Trump's own
attorney general Bill Barr said there
was no fraud undermining Joe Biden's win
and he did it after Trump's own
officials like Christopher Krebs said
this was the safest most secure election
in U.S history the same thing that
Trump's agencies like the Department of
Homeland Security said after all of that
as the congressman said you could put
any Purdy words on it you can scream
Marbury versus Madison or any other
Supreme Court precedent what Jim Jordan
did by forwarding that text was obstruct
an official proceeding and that statute
which is a 20-year felony says if you so
that's what glamus Glenn is claiming
here is that he um Jim Jordan is trying
to obstruct as a congressperson that's
what Glenn is claiming here and and I
also remember also remember that this is
Jim I don't recall how many times I
spoke to president Trump on January 6th
I call him I call him Jim I don't report
sex crimes Jordan that's my [ __ ] it's
kind of a long nickname but it's kind of
catchy Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan yeah I think that's appropriate
Jesus
you attempt to obstruct or you Endeavor
to impede an official Congressional
proceeding like Again Jim Jordan is very
good at trying to obstruct
um Jim Jordan is also like back on the
you know won't report sexual assault he
will keep his mouth shut about sexual
assault but then we'll we'll yell
or as loud as he can about random things
when he's on some committee meeting you
know right well and again I want the
folks that are listening to know that
I'm not necessarily disagreeing with
Glenn here but I think the the Democrats
the left the people who are wanting a
trump and these [ __ ] idiots like Jim
I don't report sex drives Jordan to be
held accountable to not jump to so many
conclusions about what doj the Court's
gonna do because I actually believe that
Glenn is right here if he is right if he
is correct I think Jim Jordan's gonna be
in a hell of a lot of trouble so let's
um let me play because this is another
two minute clip but I want to give Glenn
his due I don't want to just let people
think that I'm writing Glenn off here
because uh I think Glenn's a smart guy I
think Glenn knows he's a former
prosecutor which to be honest I'm not
always fan of former prosecutors but
but let's let's um let's listen so let's
talk about some of the text message I do
want to point out Glenn I am going to
criticize you here that your mic for
this video is really good so whatever
mic you're using for this video you need
to use that on Joy show I'm just saying
just received by watch Meadows on
January 6th that we're just released
let's turn to one text in particular
one from Jim Jordan the text message
from Jordan two Meadows released by the
committee on Monday red
on January 6 2021 vice president Mike
Pence as president of the Senate should
call out all electoral votes that he
believes are unconstitutional as no
electoral votes at all okay so this is
what he's saying is Criminal because
this is where he's saying that
Jim Jordan is trying to obviously trying
to obstruct
um an official proceeding by saying this
now yeah so before we get to that my
thing is here if Maga and the Trump
supporters and people are so [ __ ]
upset about January 6 and people calling
it Insurrection and they're talking
about political prisoners and all this
[ __ ]
can you even [ __ ] imagine if you just
changed a few names in this [ __ ] in
in this oh easily yeah yeah if you were
to just change a few names yeah yeah
it would be treason yeah they would be
yelling about it but the other thing too
is
you know they're always like don't call
it Insurrection don't do this it was
just this is like okay well then let's
just investigate it like what's a big
deal right well so here's here's the
problem though is that they really they
really are on both sides of the fence
here and the reason why is because if
this is the truth if Jim Jordan is
genuine in this text which he may be he
may not be we never know Jim Jordan is a
[ __ ] scumbag right but if he really
believes that on January 6 2021 vice
president Mike Pence as the president of
the Senate that Duty right he's the vice
president he has the duty of the prison
the Senate you have to remember he's
talking about the offices and the seats
that he's holding should call out all
electoral votes that he believes are
unconstitutional
so think about this for a second if Jim
Jordan believes that Mike Pence should
do that or in the past should have done
that
wouldn't that lead Jim Jordan to believe
today that maybe Mike Pence looked at
those votes and seen them as
constitutional this really is
bone-headed type [ __ ] here yeah well
it's one of those things where it's like
it's only like well he wants Pence to to
do his job to to remove or keep whatever
votes he thinks are constitutional are
unconstitutional uh but it's like yeah
if the assumption is he already looked
at them and said these look good to me
right that's not you should agree yeah
right but it's not good enough for Jim
Jordan because it doesn't fit the
narrative that's right because that's
when everyone was like we're gonna
[ __ ] hang Mike Pence but I think
that's I think that's what Glenn's gonna
say here though is that Mike Pence did
do his duty as vice president and
president of the Senate and inspected
the votes if that's what you want to
call it which is not the thing that Mike
Pence does he's just presiding over the
joint session is all he's doing Mike
Pence has nothing to do with calling the
votes a constitution or not that's all
[ __ ] yeah that's all [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's just he's just presiding
over the hearing or the The Joint
session is all he's doing it's almost
like it's almost like Jim Jordan uh like
I don't know if you remember when we
were kids and stuff when you'd be like
oh he you know he or she loves me you
know he or she loves me not and you're
like oh yeah it's like they're looking
at whatever one you land on right yeah
it's like whatever the ballots are and
they're like oh okay
you just make it whatever you want
exactly right and you land on the pedal
that you want to land yeah
exactly the eeny meeny miny moe and you
just keep going until yeah or like you
double count you're like Mining and you
know and you're like great Mo yeah well
let's see what else Glenn has to say
here
and Jim Jordan made this statement
urging Mike Pence to just throw out
votes
votes that let's be clear were going to
be cast for Joe Biden but see I actually
don't think that's what he's saying here
what he's saying here is that he
literally is saying votes that he
believes are unconstitutional so in
other words if Mike Pence believes that
they're unconstitutional then he should
do what I'm saying he should do but he
didn't do that right but isn't it I mean
isn't that one in the same though like
any vote for Biden is quote unquote
unconstitutional because they're going
to like but but that but that goes into
that goes into a criminal court proving
his intent right yeah yeah so so is his
intent here is to say that he wants Mike
Pence to do the right thing or is his
intent here he wants Mike Pence to try
to Crown Donald Trump trump King right I
would go with the latter right exactly
well and that's what I'm saying about
how he's wording this because if he
really believes this because his intent
is not just with this text message his
intent is going to be be proven if it
goes to a criminal court his intent will
be proven with all his text messages
after and all his actions and and his
statements after which if that is true
his intent here was to overthrow the
government in the United States not not
to let Mike Pence make the decision and
he live with that decision that's my I
don't know so I appreciate Glenn's um
perspective on this and I think we
should you know I'm going to retweet it
because I think we should take these
into consideration and this this is a
debate this is that this country should
have and the reason why we should have
is because a lot of people are saying oh
the Department of Justice is not going
to hold people accountable well guess
who gets to hold the meccano we do and
if you keep saying that they're not
going to hold them accountable then and
they don't then there's nothing we can
do so I appreciate Glenn's perspective
on this
um even though I I don't I mean my
opinion what who am I right but yeah who
are you yeah that's right okay
let's get let's get to the dishonorable
mention because we want to bring her up
we always have a dishonorable mention
every week
um Laura Trump and um we want to play a
video now let's see should we play the
wine video I feel like a mother of the
year give it to him let's let's do that
one let's do that one because we have
the video where she's talking about how
Trump tried to stop the January 6th
Insurrection or something which is just
it's like it's [ __ ] right it's the
revisionism for me you know and it's
[ __ ] but this one this one is so
much more Laura Trump
um to set this one up this let's set
this one up number one she she's
drinking Trump wine which you know has
got to be disgusting as [ __ ] that's why
she only takes one sip I didn't even
know they still made Trump one right I
thought it was defunct I'm gonna I'm
gonna mute it so we can just play it on
a loop here while we're talking about it
because it's it's just takes a sip
and then her daughter is just crying
right and complaining and then she's
like I'm just gonna ignore you and then
do this look at the Trump candle here
this is the best they got folks this is
supposed to be class this is literally
like a one a dollar store candle with
the [ __ ] 50 Cent label that they
printed in a [ __ ] inkjit and slapped
on that [ __ ]
I wouldn't be surprised if they were
like buying Yankee Candles from Bed Bath
and Beyond and then just because they're
melting them down yeah
I can just stick it a sticker over top
of them oh absolutely and then I wonder
why I wonder I wonder yeah again like I
did not even know that they made wine is
that like a rose I don't know what the
[ __ ] that is or like a Zen or something
I'm not much of a wine guy but it's
probably Boone's Farm that they've
remodeled yeah or like uh
what are the other ones that are I want
to go back here too because I want to
show that the shirt she's got on yeah it
says
yeah it says mom
let's see if I can get a good shot of it
here
mom life mom life so not only did she
get the wine the cheap ass wine and the
candle out on the table she she went to
her room put her mom life shirt on
because she had the nanny bring the
whining kid in so that she could make
this video right right yeah so that she
because you know it she's not walking
around in a [ __ ] shirt that says mom
life with that [ __ ] nanny is taking
care of the kid man come on get get the
[ __ ] out of here yeah there was a there
was definitely a wardrobe makeup change
to make this video as soon as she
finishes she's like okay take the kid
away like that's the type of parents
that the trumps are where they will like
so this is premeditated High crimes 100
100 you know and I think the fact that
the daughter is like crying off on the
side is maybe in her mind is supposed to
validate more was like oh I totally get
what being a parent is like am I right
and it's like yeah that's why I'm
getting drunk when I'm watching my kid
behind the like kitchen door is like the
The Nanny or the au pair or whatever is
just like waiting to be like right go
grab the kid now right right right right
it's crying I want to stop it from
crying because right you're making it
cry you [ __ ] right I knew the c word
would come out eventually
oh this I I just I I would much rather
play this this fake ass video than her
fake ass video where she says Donald
Trump was trying to stop January because
this is just as fake as that like this
is just as much performance art as the
one and let's also not forget for anyone
listening or watching that Lara Trump
did steal nearly two million dollars
from uh a dog charity well I mean well
and didn't Eric steal from insurance
yeah yeah he stole from it was a Cancer
Foundation well I mean there's such
concerned parents you know yeah they
love the kids and they love that they
love Mama that they're like Mom I make
money life right exactly exactly
two peas in a pod they were meant for
each other whether one inspires the
other to be the criminal or it's just
like they inherit the name and they're
like well might as well [ __ ] them yeah
right [ __ ] them you know that Eric
didn't have fall the far from the
bonehead tree though so no yeah you know
and I I don't know much about her
background but I don't know much about
her except for the fact that she is you
know
part of the family now that's been given
things and has money definitely married
down I'm gonna say that like well I mean
she's really good down when you marry
Aaron well right but I mean she's she's
really good at the grift like she's one
of the ones like she's I think she's
better in Ivanka at the grift really
honestly she's like you know she does
the I'm from North Carolina and that
kind of [ __ ] and she you know she's the
Yokel she's not the high Brown you know
this mom life [ __ ] where she's lighting
candles and as if she got her like
little rustic Barn table right right in
the dining room she's never been in yeah
yeah I get it yeah all right well you
know I I think we got the boneheads and
let's give let's give the video one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
all right so thanks for joining us for
the for the this edition of bonehead of
the week we went a little long because
we really had to sort through Gabe's
obsession with Christian Walker listen
him being his roommate you know it's
like him being his roommate over at UCLA
or you know just on the internet just on
the internet you're his roommate at UCLA
so yes just on the internet just on the
internet uh don't don't forget to go
vote
um for bonehead of the week follow us on
on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod that's
where the uh hopefully I'll post it
correctly again this week where it goes
for both of our six I hope so yeah yeah
and follow Gabe at I am Gabe Sanchez and
and follow me at the Tony Michaels
um also on Twitter but the the the poll
will be on the podcast page and we'll
try to retweet that out and I'll try to
make sure that the guy's setting up the
bowl this week gets it going all week so
stay tuned for that also we have a great
interview coming up Gabe this week on
the podcast guest Wednesday three
o'clock Central four o'clock Eastern uh
John Walsh have you ever heard of John
Walsh uh I believe so yes he's famous on
Tick Tock he's got like one million Tick
Tock followers but I discovered a lot of
stuff about John in our interview that I
did not know and we also play a really
good trivia game so uh everyone should
go check that out this week Wednesday
three o'clock Central four o'clock
Eastern now you have to edit that
interview uh regardless you have to get
it done now that we've floated it and
told the audience that we're gonna play
it so three o'clock Eastern four o'clock
Eastern podcast also check check out
uh every weekday
well I do this [ __ ] list Roundup on
Twitter and twitch so check that out and
go subscribe to our YouTube channel
don't miss any any of the videos rather
it's the podcast the [ __ ] list Roundup
or the bonehead of the week here we post
that all on the YouTube channel so go go
follow us over there too if you want to
watch us on YouTube or on Twitch we put
this all this stuff on Twitch too so go
check us out sorry we went a little long
but we really have these we really had
to unpack the Christian Walker Gabe
Sanchez Saga roommate Saga yeah um so I
really wanted to unpack that so I
appreciate you guys joining us come back
next week thanks for joining us bone of
the week oh before I go [ __ ] up [ __ ] em
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]